The world will mark an important milestone
as the global population surpasses 8 billion people.
Weddings are back.
Experts are predicting weddings to reach a
40-year high.
We have been waiting to do this for two-and-a-half
years.
After weeks of flirtation and fighting
the new couple has officially done the deed.
[Laughing]
Full-on crypto crash.
$32 billion dollars just vanished…
My money don’t jiggle jiggle.
BTS are going on hiatus.
Taylor Swift fans waited hours online only
to find the website crashing.
I’m going to the concert!
The final seconds before impact.
[Slap]
Have a corn-tastic day.
Ah, stunning! Yeah.
The blockbuster legal saga between Amber Heard
and Johnny Depp…
My favorite thing about the movie is like,
it feels like a…
like a… movie.
The Russian president says a military operation
is now underway in eastern Ukraine.
Explosions and air raid sirens ringing out
in cities across this country.
Soaring new numbers from the UN on Ukrainians
fleeing the fighting.
We cry — we all have the feeling that we’ve
no home.
[In Russian] We are ready for any outcome.
Russia, now the target of more than 2,700
new sanctions.
And the world bracing for food shortages
Russia has now suspended all gas supplies
to Germany.
Possible explosions along the Nord Stream
pipelines.
Gas prices — soaring to the highest average
ever recorded.
Amazon,
Microsoft,
Meta announced 11,000 employees laid off
[Twitter notification]
1,200 Twitter employees calling it quits.
I quit is what’s going on.
[Screaming] Ah, ****
Inflation
is much too high.
Everything has doubled up.
Do you heat or do you eat?
These prices are totally outrageous.
I do not have time for this!
[BeReal notification]
It’s been the most incredible ride and journey
I’ve ever been on.
[Cheering]
We have finally achieved equal pay for our
men’s and our women’s national team.
It’s about damn time.
It is the most controversial World Cup in
the history of football.
The gulf state’s been under intense scrutiny
over the treatment of migrant workers.
The 2022 Winter Olympics are underway.
Jamaica will compete in the four-man bobsled.
China’s snow princess is the queen of big air!
Russian figure skater testing positive for
a banned substance.
I have tested positive for Covid-19.
I will have to withdraw.
BA.5 is fueling yet another wave
Covid vaccines for children under 5 began
today.
Someone’s getting vaccinated.
Airline passengers can now decide for themselves
to wear a mask.
Summer travel this year comes with some baggage.
Kylie Jenner takes a three-minute flight and
yet they’re telling me to recycle cans!
Soaring temperatures.
40.2 degrees
[Speaking Portuguese] Get out of there, please!
Pakistan reeling from the devastating floods
caused by monsoon rains.
We are on a highway to climate hell
with our foot still on the accelerator.
Hurricane Ian has changed Florida forever.
This wall could not contain it because the
water was too much.
We are seeing tragedy unraveling in front
of our eyes.
[Gasp]
[Speaking Arabic] We were working here, and
suddenly, we heard mortar explosions near this mosque.
This crater hints at the size of the explosion
in western Ghana.
The government of Burkina Faso averted a plot
to take over the country.
Today, we have fought for our freedom from
the greedy politicians.
154 people were killed in a crush in South Korea.
Another mass shooting…
At a fourth of July parade,
In a Walmart,
At a hospital complex,
At a gay nightclub,
An elementary school in Uvalde, Texas.
They let our baby get slaughtered.
A major Supreme Court ruling that could make
it easier to obtain a firearm license.
Antisemitic incidents…
Black transgender deaths are rising.
Critics call it the “don’t say gay” bill.
We will not go back!
The nation’s highest court ruling to overturn Roe v. Wade.
Our body, our choice!
22-year-old Mahsa Amini was taken into custody
by Iran’s morality police.
Amini’s death has sparked outrage.
The Iranian squad chose not to sing the country’s
national anthem.
Please be our voice and don’t let the evil
regime kill innocent people.
Palestinian journalist Shireen Abu Akleh has
been shot dead.
Thousands gathered for her funeral procession.
[Chanting in Mandarin] Not lies, but respect!
Authorities in China are strengthening their
efforts to stamp out unrest over stringent
Covid measures.
[Speaking Ukrainian] The citizens are here.
We are here.
[Piano music]
I want you to know how sad I am to be giving
up the best job in the world.
I am resigning as leader of the conservative party.
I am prepared to give everything I have.
Xi Jinping — becomes the most powerful leader
in China in decades.
Jair Bolsonaro defeated by former president
Lula da Silva.
Gabriel Boric will become Chile’s youngest
ever president.
Republicans were hoping for a red wave, which
didn’t really pan out.
Giorgia Meloni’s “Brothers of Italy”
party winning this weekend’s election.
India’s first tribal person elected to the
highest office of the land.
Buckingham Palace has announced the death
of her majesty Queen Elizabeth the second.
[Canon fire]
This is the end of an era.
Ukrainian forces are now on the offensive.
They’ve taken more territory in the past
week than Russia has since April.
Nobody’s gonna break us.
We are strong.
We are Ukrainians.
WNBA star Brittney Griner is headed home.
I’m about to sign the Inflation Reduction Act…
…The largest US commitment ever to fighting climate change.
Cuba holding a landmark referendum to legalize
same-sex marriage.
Yes!
[Speaking Spanish] Argentina!
Champions of the world!
Every image is a new discovery and each will
give humanity a view of the universe that
we’ve never seen before.
Thank you to the Academy for letting our Coda
make history tonight.
And don’t you ever, ever give up on you.
It is a long journey to this moment.
In my family, it took just one generation
to go from segregation to the Supreme Court
of the United States.
History is not about statistics and memorizing
dates and boring quotations.
History is about people.
It’s about human beings.